It's possible to get unlucky using direct mapped caches, in
that different blocks that are important to your application might get
mapped to the same index in the cache. For instance,
if an application happens to access two cache lines that have
the same index, maybe this one and this one here,
then they will constantly be evicting each other from the cache.
And it, it will be essentially useless. This, of course, is
rather silly given that there are all these other entries in
the cache that aren't getting used at all. The
fundamental problem is that the address, any one of these
here, is only associated with one location in the
cache. We can mitigate these effects by associating an address
with more than one block in the cache. One
strategy is to treat all the red lines as blue
ones, and all of the orange lines as green ones.
If we do this then we'll have twice as many
places in the cache to store a blue line of memory.
Actually, it's more convenient to think about the blue lines in
the cache being together. And in this way, we can say
that we have simply decided to ignore the most significant bit of
our previous index, but to allow a cache block to now
be stored in two possible places. Hence, this would be called a
two way associative cache. The downside is that we have to
check two tags now to see if we have a cache hit.
But we are less likely run into a problem, where
we are constantly evicting the memory we need from the cache.
If we decide this isn't good enough, we can halve the
number of indices again to create a four way associative cache.
Returning to our general notation, we now say that we have
2 to the j associativity. This means that we only have
two to the k minus j indices into our cache, and
the index is really only k minus j bits long now.
This greater associativity also gives the cache
some choice about replacement. Whereas with the
direct mount cache, there was only one block in the cache where the data could
be stored. We now have a set of possible locations. Just two in our example
but maybe more. Typically, we choose to
evict the entry that was least recently used.